в Астані
євросоюз підписав відведення про безвізовий
режим з колумбією у іншого брешу дня на
задовго до колумбії важливий і долар упав
та sincro in africa карибського басейну
той голка а ну а також переможно не
арабські емірати Молдова напрокат
зрубала 1002 рук цьому
Україна вже замкнула руку могла б
вимовляти від україн Рамаяни яких до
зростання та цивільний в'їзд до crying
шенгенської зони
безвізовий режим знову на матч вибуху за
два дні до встановленого брюсселем
граничну терміну верховна рада уколи
латинки про dance та ми би зірку у
законопроекті
про електронне декларування доходів
по садів тиф тайтай із валізу і мало
позіханням і для проколювання майна
нами і повалятися булаву драматичного
Як би вигляд 100 його не особливо стах
інтересі в українських політиків у
складні року в Чикаго ну або ралі за
цію візового режиму
у team мало йому повернути його руку
місіонера команду вати ми лідером є
з косого ти візи для українців
а g c пройдусь ним політичне рішення
безвізовий режим c сигнал і часті не
українського suspect'а нібито мо-аі смі
на капіталі майор форма багато знання не
треба мене
безвізового режиму з петренко анти
антарів армійських сил
доця бути його буддизмі його ти баланс і
консолідацію на у power for both so року
1 показані в персеполі рішення будуть
тусувався у знанні за україну
європейського статусу
ріж то безвізових законі ось по праву
верховна рада витків до четверга edition
pro спеціальну конфіскацію покликав його
не генерального прокурора право про
означають з перу hipster
спеціалізовану антикорупційну
прокуратури
законодавства рахунок та дискримінації
що теж у четвер в астані день на
пройдуть не падаючи
єврокомісію зв туди заради документа
обіцяти виродок 6 хвалить і в злочинності
президента порошенка